alors juste avant qu'on en parle donne
quelques chiffres par et il sait ce qu
on lit un post sur les réseaux sociaux
kev adams ce sera au tour de 10000 euros
la photo hery smit et narre donc là la
mise entre 5000 et 10000 euros la photo
jennifer entre 10000 et 15000 euros la
photo je reconnais que ça paraît énorme
ça paraît énorme pour une publicité à
chaque fois alors forcément on va
demander quand même à celle qui qui
s'est le mieux tout ça parce que c'est
là c'est la papesse de la télé réalité
et des réseaux sociaux
c'est vrai on peut le dire vous avez
fait fortune grâce à ça vous êtes un
complément dans quatre veaux et bravo ça
c'est une très belle réussite
c'est une très belle réussite galibert
d'âge du connu à dole d'enterrer valise
en carton elle mais elle était venue
comme ça dans mon bureau avec une petite
valise tennessee qui travaille beaucoup
vous avez raison de dire mathieu parce
que c'est remarquable à une époque où
les femmes sont encore le plafond de
verre pour réussir à 35 ans elle a créé
inventé un vrai business en france voilà
remarquable et donc j'aimerais savoir
l'issue les chiffres les chiffres ça va
de combien à combien qu'est ce qu'on
peut dire alors alors tout des followers
la notoriété de l'actualité ça dépend de
combien notre followers akouala de la
notoriété et de l'actualité parce qu'à
des gens qui ont un million de followers
qu'il marche absolument pas mais s'ils
n'ont pas de notoriété n'y a pas de
visibilité il se passe rien
donc quand on a pu par exemple très
concret à une ayem qui entraîna plus
d'émissions de télévision et tout ça
quand on a plus d'actualité du synaps
dans l'allée de son cachet sur la
publicité pascal yama tourner une
publicité télé c'était ça le sujet
s'était passé revenu mensuel d'accord
mon poste ce alors nabila j'ai lu nabila
peut-être couvrait pas en parler mais
j'ai une habile à 70000 euros par mois
c'est pas vrai c'est pas ça mais elle
peut pas dire les vrais gens ne veut pas
dire est vrai déjà que pas ces
chiffres-là ensuite nabil aujourd'hui
elle a des postes sur les réseaux
sociaux
et elle a aussi des campagnes
publicitaires moi j'aurais juste correct
sociaux voilà oui luc par moi j'ai des
chiffres que tu avais demandé où
j'allais voir une annonceurs à moi je
dis combien les gens achètent des
patrons journal où les gens peuvent
acheter celles des concurrents pour moi
également ces gens là très bien et ils
m'ont dit jean haja et phoenix pour un
blog c'est à dire si elle va restaurer
story dire ah j'ai pris ma came solaire
mais juste le dis comme ça
sept mille euros était non négociable
obligé de payer ça tu peux pas dire mais
si elle en fait trois jours il va
maintenant si elle fait un blog qu'elle
parle que de ça ses 13000 sa nana ce
klaus il influence est très connue alors
que plus elle fait que style de la
beauté etc pour une publication sur sa
story c'est 7000 euros sur son blog ses
13000 emma cupcake et elles sont pas
très connus c'est fini pour prendre rang
des millions de followers elle aussi ses
7000 euros pour les instincts sort est
scellé
chiffre que les agents envoyés à la fis
pour finir si tu fais de la pub c'est ça
juste comprendre la galice et qu'on
comprend que les normes tard justin
bieber qui dit utiliser tel dentifrice
sylla il a 70 ans oui on comprend que ça
marche pour des pour des gens comme des
français qu'on 203 100 1000 followers
des gens de télé réalité et tout ça
c'est si vous leur donnez on va dire
trois ou cinq mille euros le poste ça
veut dire que pour la marque ça leur
apporte moins trois fois c'est ça et une
vraie économie derrière on a ce que l'on
appelle les codes promo sous les photos
qui permet aux qui permettent aux
marques d'identifier immédiatement le
retour sur investissement donc la marque
elle a un retour immédiat et
effectivement c'est une nouvelle
économie
derrière ça fait vivre des entreprises
ça fait vivre des gens parce qu'à des
salariés ou des packs qui vole l'argent
j'aimerais des montants j'aimerais les
montées pas non plus de très jolies
marques un habile à neutrons de la villa
vient faire une promo sur cacharel via
le real merci pour la marque offre le me
3 secondes voilà merci beaucoup mais
c'est vrai que ça pas moi moi j'ai
entendu des montants comme quarante ou
cinquante mille euros
on peut comprendre que ça paraît énorme
pour que nabila ben et touche 50 mais
euros par mois en âge aujourd'hui
qu'elle s'est créé effectivement à côté
de ça pourquoi aujourd'hui une marque va
gagner des dizaines de milliers d'euros
grâce à nabila et la payer 500 euros
personne n'accepterait ça faut pas se
mentir on peut pas être hypocrite
donc les prix maintenant au niveau des
tranches effectivement ça démarre en
france à 300 euros le poste pour des
petits influenceurs et ça peut monter
jusqu'à 15000 euros
ça c'est l'état alors juste en effet
manqué quelques noms peut-être
d'animateur ou de chroniqueurs deux
trois noms d'animateur ou 2 ou 2 ou de
gens de télé réalité qui fonctionne le
mieux qui touchent le plus d'argent
bon télé réalité on a g6 cative nabila
effectivement qui sont même au niveau
des followers les plus la corse encore
autant d'argent sur la toile ensuite au
niveau animateurs aujourd'hui dans mon
réseau d'animateurs j'en ai un qui
marche très très bien ses matches et de
lamanon non
allez johnny hallyday
alors non à la cour cyril n'a pas de
zizi je n'ai pas de portefeuille
non non je sais comme ils n'osent pas
sur moi ça me fait pas rire alors les
rumeurs on a fait un petit jeu on a fait
un petit jeu trois secondes ne s'est
posé la question si vous étiez connu ce
n'est pas le cas de nombreux jeunes
selon votre nombre de followers et donc
de deux célébrités
qu'est ce que vous pourriez ramené par
poste si on fait un petit calcul selon
les magali berda alors regardez on sait
voilà on a eu on a eu les chiffres à moi
je suis là alors voilà voilà voilà alors
ça c'est magali magali magali situe
postait site si tu fais un puck et
gagnerait 2 pourquoi ces hangars de 235
dollars selon une autorité aujourd'hui
voilà tu gagnerais 235 dollars si tu
faisais un pote aujourd'hui nagl et les
voilà à coeur non là sébastien ce qu'ont
à sébastien derrière sébastien ta 4802
4817 follower tu gagnerais entre 33 et
55 euros tu vois un pv delphine 182 1000
followers défilent ça monte un peu tu
seras entre 500 et 800 euros par poste
voilà des films ton pote on peut la
vérité aussi un oui j'en passe et voilà
et en vrai de vrai c'est un peu plus
cher que ça mais en vrai j'écoute le
boss qui a dit ne pas parler d'argent
effectivement mais l'on sait plus gagner
plus et le dernier sait qui c'est qui
c'est qui c'est moi c'est moi c'est moi
397 1000 followers donc je gagnerai
entre 1000 et 1700 euros par poste est
le seul à être à poil sur la couverture
et comme j'ai dit toute la vérité parce
qu'on parle tout le temps les autres et
que du coup bas sur parle moi j'ai un
petit peu en vrai je peux dire la vérité
c'est un petit peu plus
c'est vrai voilà j'ai touché un petit
peu plus que ça je pense que tu es revue
un petit peu à peu à la baisse
et c'est vrai que c'est malgré tout oui
c'est un bel eldorado tu apprends des
failles dieu non plus je sais que le
jour où ça marchera plus on voudra plus
nous bam en 3 secondes
on serre la vis et s'est terminé alors
ça y est vous serez plus dans l'émission
journal